the exit poll is predicting is  indicating it's a conservative win that  the Conservatives will have 368 seats  [Laughter]  Qian yellow Susan in water  21500 want to also make it clear that I  will not lead the party in any future  general election campaign  have you lost received miss Wilson and I  declare that Amy Callahan has elected to  serve in the United Kingdom Parliament  as the member for the Eastern  Partnership Elin Pelin taken statutes  [Applause]  I hereby declare that the said Boris  Johnson is duly elected at this stage it  does look as though this one nation  Conservative government has been given a  powerful new mandate well that's it  confirmation of the result the  Conservatives have formally won this  general election  [Music]